welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and after the turkey blew up stomachs on
Thanksgiving the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special blew mines everywhere
with the Revelation that mantis has been
Peter Quill's sister the entire time as
both of them are the spawn of the worst
father of all time who really ain't
trying to hear about none of that child
support [ __ ] ego The Living Planet
but what could this mean for mantis
exactly because that's a big question a
lot of people had after the special well
I have a feeling that the much
underrated mantis is a lot more powerful
and important than we all realize and
that Marvel Studios could be setting
mantis up for a massively important
Cosmic role in the MCU much like the
character was destined to in the Marvel
Comics let's get into it my nerd babies
but first do not forget to hit up new
rockstarsmarch.com to pick up one of our
newest latest Obsession shirts inspired
by black panther wakanda forever it's
not gonna last forever so pick that up
today or any of our other amazing nerd
options over at Durock saysmerch.com
alright so I have had a feeling for
years now that mantis was the child of
ego The Living Planet I mean not just
because ego typically didn't hang out
with Mortal beings that were of no use
to him because he just really he loved
himself a lot but mostly because of the
important Cosmic role that Marvel Comics
placed on mantis when her character was
first introduced and integrated into the
Avengers team for a good while in the
comics mantis was actually regarded as
one of the most valuable beings in the
entire universe because she was
discovered to be a little something
called the celestial Madonna of the
Marvel Universe while in the past in
real life the term Madonna has typically
been associated with Material Girls in a
material world it's more associated with
the character of the Virgin Mary from
the Bible the mother of the Messiah
Jesus Christ so in a similar fashion the
celestial Madonna was believed to be the
perfect being that would birth the
perfect Universal Messiah That was
supposed to change the course of the
universe forever a birth that would
eventually come to pass after mantis
boned an alien plant and made a weird
human alien plant hybrid that she named
Sequoia after the strong Earth tree
which ended up being a great name
because that [ __ ] had some
bark-ass skin his skin was literally
bark and this video is brought to you by
the ridge everyone's gotta have a wallet
okay but that doesn't mean you got to
have some bulky things that forces you
to lean left whenever you sit down
that's uncomfortable the ridge makes
stylish slim wallets that have room for
everything that you need Ridge wallets
hold up to 12 cards with room for cash
and each wallet is made with RFID
blocking technology to protect you from
digital pickpockets there are over 30
colors and styles including carbon fiber
burnt titanium and the durable material
means each wallet comes with a lifetime
warranty in fact the ridge team is so
confident that you'll like it that
they'll let you test drive it for 45
days and you can send it back with a
full refund if you don't love it but
these wallets have over like 50 000 5
Star reviews so you know you're probably
gonna love it so go to ridge.com new
rockstars and you can save up to 40
between now and December 22nd that's
ridge.com new rockstars to save up to 40
between now and December 22nd now while
I don't think Marvel Studios is going to
follow mantis's extremely convoluted
story from the comics as we can clearly
see MCU mantis already having far
different Origins than her comic book
counterpart I do think that mantis will
end up being revealed as the MCU
Celestial Madonna or Celestial mother
and that she herself could be the key to
changing the fate of the universe
because of her newly revealed Celestial
lineage and a huge reason why I believe
this lies within mantis's big scene from
Avengers Infinity War remember that
scene if you don't remember it don't
worry they deleted that [ __ ] it wasn't a
movie at all but in this deleted scene
while the Avengers and Guardians fight
Thanos on Titan Thanos uses The Infinity
Gauntlet to remove all the souls from
the bodies of the Guardians of the
Galaxy leaving Doctor Strange no choice
but to rely on mantis herself to save
the Guardians as he kept fighting Thanos
With a Little Help From a friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man take a look
Thanos separated their souls from their
bodies they're out too long they will
die know how to fix that no I know you
don't but she does
and after Spider-Man rounds up the
lifeless bodies of the Guardians from
falling to their deaths this happens
wake
it's not working well you could do this
you can do the wizard says you could do
it they're dying
after Doctor Strange used the time Stone
to predict the coming conflict with
Thanos he saw a glimpse of mantis's true
Celestial potential and he knew that she
had the ability to manipulate the soul
energies within the human body even
before mantis did apparently because
mantis did not have the faith in herself
to do such a doctor strange level task
on her own but much like she did when
she forced ego to sleep at the end of
Guardians 2 she believed in her
Celestial abilities just enough to
transfer Drax and the rest of the
Guardians his life forces back into
their bodies life forces that glowed
blue much like we saw when Wu's life
force glow right before a dragon who was
purple took a sip and a slurple of his
soul and this is of course likely due to
mantis's connection to her Celestial
father ego who himself was entirely a
big-ass blue brain with blue energy
tentacles making Kurt Russell and David
Hasselhoff puppets and ever since
erishim had their Cosmic chat with
Cersei about the roles of celestials in
the universe to farm the energy of
living beings like batteries to create
more celestials mantis having the
ability to channel the life force of
living beings would make sense but what
is particularly interesting about mantis
are the powers of persuasion that she
demonstrated during the guardian's
holiday special like when she kidnapped
Kevin Bacon and robbed that lady of all
of her money making mantis my favorite
MCU villain of all time gave me all your
money this is significant to me
particularly because it reminded me of
one of the ideas Gilgamesh of the
eternals had to try to take down the
celestials by having the Mind
controlling Druid use his powers on them
could Drew control its mind
maybe put it to sleep now if mantis is
powerful enough to put even the most
powerful Immortals like Thanos in a
trance and God likes celestials like ego
to sleep the MCU could be setting mantas
up to be the new leader of the
celestials possibly after erisham
somehow gets taken out of the equation
by the eternals in a sequel project
because as we know from the end of
eternals arrows of Titan AKA Star Fox is
bringing Makari Fina and Druid right to
erishim's HQ at the world Forge to
rescue their friend so if Druid were to
find a way to I don't know tell erichem
to go take a bath with a toaster a new
vacancy for Celestial leader could be
open for the celestial Madonna to come
in however we can't completely shut out
the idea of the MCU introducing mantis's
son Sequoia to the MCU either because as
we've seen with the introduction of
Morgan Stark in endgame Billy and Tommy
and one division love in 4-4 and Tucson
in wakanda forever it seems like the MCU
is setting up the seeds for the next
generation of Heroes to come to the MCU
one way or another and seeing as king
the Conqueror is said to be the big bad
of the Multiverse Saga a big bad who in
the comics actually tried to kid that
mantis so that he could use the
prophesied celestial Messiah to conquer
the Universe I could see a scenario
where time travel Shenanigans give us a
look at the near MCU future where all of
these kids are grown up including
Sequoia so a Celestial Messiah could
potentially factor into both Kang
Dynasty or even a secret War scenario
but what do you guys think how do you
guys feel about mantis being a Celestial
being and you guys feel like she's going
to play a huge important role in the MCU
as a Celestial Madonna like she does in
the comics let us know in the comment
section below but anyways thank you guys
so much for watching this video you can
follow me at Master attainment on
Twitter if you want to see me tweet some
weird [ __ ] but most importantly you can
follow new rockstars wherever we are on
the internet and when you do on YouTube
make sure you hit that notification Bell
so that you can get notifications every
time we upload a video which is pretty
damn often and of course do not forget
to hit up new rockstars merch.com to
pick up our newest latest obsessive
shirts inspired by wakanda forever or
any of our other amazing nerd options
over there truly and it's the best gift
to give your loved one for the holidays
because there's nerds and everywhere and
everyone loves a good black panther or
an Iron Man inspired shirt but yeah
thank you guys so much for spending time
with me I appreciate it always and I'll
see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]